I not been back to him years but it was
the last place left to look
it was not exactly as I remembered it
but it wasn't all that different I've
too odd contraptions guarded the lost
treasure I would have to turn on and see
what happened
and that's what would have happened if i
turn the left switch but since i am here
telling the story you already know that
i pulled the right one
mark its bowels butter churns and beds
were jammed and every nook and cranny of
that cave all seems all familiar
Marcus bowels monitor the beds were
jammed and every nook and cranny of that
cave all seemed so familiar even though
the bed was very comfortable this was no
time to hide under the covers
whoa wait hold on grandpa I don't
remember this part of the story thats
hanging from stalactites will get that
went of it no worry no detail in the
story will be overloaded now where was i
ah yes as I treaded through the river
rumbling tunnels i feared i knew the
source of that deafening wind
nestled beneath a slumbering pile of
teeth and claws was fabled mirror oh oh
you remember this part of the story well
dragons are my favorite you want to tell
this part yes King Edward sent me the
greatest Knight in all of Daventry on a
quest to return hit stole a mirror a
gigantic hulking beast of a dragon was
the last thing in my way to in my way to
my way to add a shinier hat to my
collection
I tried and her that crazy contraption
but it was missing a handle someone
added with it creating some silly
conundrum
as I was saying hmm this was no time to
take to that
so the missing handle was booby trapped
what did you do well I use my cleverness
to outsmart the trap
yeah I use my cleverness to hide
luckily that half blighted beasts never
noticed me in bed dragons I must be
really hard to pierce with an arrow at
archery lessons I can barely hit a hay
bale it is indeed a feed holy for
skilled archers
I tried it her that crazy contraption
but it was missing a handle someone
effort with it creating some silly
conundrum what do you used
the dragons chains were coiled around a
gigantic switch mounted to the cave wall
after he briefly bastid the Sun the
narcoleptic dragon went back to snoring
I probably sleep all day too if mirror
was my only friend
whoever designed this trap thought they
were pretty clever but I would properly
find a way they hit that unbreachable
switch
you
the mirror call out to me
you
with a magic mirror safely in my
possession I dreamt of a Daventry I
would be rewarded with and a kingdom it
could become
and that split second I had three
choices in front of me any clearer by
Pat the safety and all will have
rippling consequences
my hands were shaking my arms could
barely grip the rope but were the last
of my strength I climbed out of the well
and headed back to the castle ever since
the magic mirror returned its
reflections the horn the kingdom of
danger kept our family safe and it has
exposed many troublesome crumbs tangled
in my beer yeah yeah yeah King Edward
was so proud that you returned his lost
treasure and that he made you came
everyone knows that part now can we get
back to that dragon wendelin there's so
much more to my stories and dragons I
hope this whole camp will be remembered
for far more than the action tattooed
across its brim sewn into the seams are
many hidden adventures alright let's get
back to the dragon tell me everything
how did you know shooting the bell would
distract him over the years I realize
that the dragon was not the despicable
hideous Beast Daventry had made him out
to be he was just a caged animal that
was very hungry I too would be violently
angry if I could only eat whom are
neglectful owner rang the bell I know it
was a sneaky trick but I certainly
wasn't going to sell a dragon loose on
the town or participate in any more
abuse you really thought that through
grandma I would have tricked them to
back home they call me Gwendolyn the
smartypants you come from a long line of
logically minded nobles and one very
clever dentist all right you too grandpa
needs to rest Gwendolyn it's way past
your bedtime sleep ball guard Bob I'll
be back first thing in the morning I
don't need rest I'm a surprise I've ever
been though I would mind a slice of
magic fruit
you
you